morning this is a very long vlog I'm
sorry if your attention spans can't hi
guys
grace Helbig myself here with another
story for you because this YouTube has
come has come this YouTube didn't come
this YouTube is very anti sexual what
basically this YouTube channel has
become more like a conversational
channel where I can talk to you guys
about things and and life and stories a
couple weird things have all happened to
me in the last 48 hours sorry if this is
not news to you because I did talk about
this on my blog TV show on Monday at 3
o'clock because every Monday at 3 p.m.
Eastern Daylight Time I do a live blog
TV show this past weekend I was in
California for a wedding and I flew back
Sunday night and landed in New York
Monday morning so I flew a red-eye flew
overnight and oh I get why they call it
red eyes cuz it makes your eyes red
because you're not sleeping because
you're on the plane overnight I get kind
of anxious on planes so I didn't sleep
on the plane I tried to it's the middle
of the flight a lot of people are
sleeping I'm watching television like
half asleep and this girl walks down the
middle aisle and I have an aisle seat
because I have long legs if you don't
know I'm five foot nine and a half and
about 3/4 of my body is just strictly
legs my torso is very unprofessional to
the rest of my body my leg is like my
foot rather is a little bit in the aisle
hardly anything but the girl hits it
trips a little bit and then just passes
out completely and just like redwood
getting cut down just boom I'm wearing
sidenote a zip up Hoodie that I have my
hood over my head because I'm trying to
sleep and I don't want anyone getting in
this gray sphere and as this Redwood
girl is falling to the ground her hand
falls inside where my hoodie is and she
grabs my hoodie and pulls it down with
her and immediately my reaction is like
get off of me so I
off of me I don't even realize I'm so
tired this point but I realized that I'm
doing this but I'm pulling her hand off
of me and like pushing her away from me
to get someone finally though hits the
light above you that calls for the
flight attendant and they come they take
her back to the back of the planes but
as they pull her away we realized that
she had thrown up all in the aisle and
then when the lights went on after we
landed you just like see the stains of
it all in the aisle Oh gross but I still
really like Virgin America then I go
back to New York and I don't sleep and I
have an audition and I go to my audition
and it was totally fine and then I leave
the audition and I'm getting on the
subway to come to go to Michelle's
apartment to film a vlog which babe what
a nice thing wait he is now up live on
our Grace and Michelle channel so I'm
getting on the subway I'm sitting on the
platform waiting for the subway and I
look up and out of the corner of my eye
I see this man in front of me he takes
his hand and he goes down towards his
pants and I'm thinking oh no don't
please don't he unzips his pants pulled
out his gun and just starts shooting I
realized that's a metaphor that could be
taken literally in New York it's not a
real gun he was jerking off on the
subway platform then I get on the subway
car and I'm going to Michelle's place
it's not a very crowded subway car but
this girl she had walked down to the
other end of the subway car and showed
her earphones in she's listening to
music that made her dance like a subtle
prostitute I can't even do it justice
I'll try but I really can't like moving
her hands around like moving pelvis and
can't do it very well at all but I'll
show you the video footage that I took
of it
not the greatest footage in the world
but it was all I could do on such a
short notice so I've talked forever I'm
very sorry but this is all what has been
happening to me in the last 48 hours and
it was to me very hilarious and bizarre
series of events and I hope that you had
fun listening to this I'll see you at
some point guys make sure to go check
out Grace and Michelle bye
and don't ever jerk off on the subway
platform you think people can't see you
but they can see you and if it's that
you want them to see you that's even
worse
come on go on your computer
there's tons of [ __ ] out there I hope
you're not watching mom